bonjour à tous pourquoi chercher plus
loin sur france 3 depuis le palais
granvelle le musée du temps de besançon
pour mettre à l'honneur le travail des
magiciens de la matière capable de
transformer la terre ou la pierre en
construction ou en oeuvre d'art et même
à faire du beau avec du béton d'abord
l'argile de puiser un trésor connu
depuis le 14e siècle une terre non
poreuse vendus dans le monde entier même
jusqu'au japon
sa fabrication a d'ailleurs obtenu le
label entreprise du patrimoine vivant
direction saint amand en puisaye existe
depuis 40 ans le centre international de
formation à la céramique pour nous
offrir une leçon personnalisés avant de
nous intéresser aux techniques de
cuisson toujours très spectaculaire et
pleine de surprises
les calages l'intérieur de la cuisse
encore un petit peu à la base
il ya un léger décentrage mais tu vas
l'avoir en persan redonne un petit coup
mettons coude à l'intérieur de la cuisse
et poussèrent le centre oui la gentille
mans voilà tu là
là tu peux la platine
donc l'idée de cette formation s'est
donné un panel de forme
qui ne sont pas reproduire forcément tel
quel dans la réalité d'ateliers d'un
atelier futur mais plus tôt
10 à part apporter une touche
personnelle
donc ce ne sont que des prétextes à
aller vers d'autres formes
pour moi qui suis de la région et qui
est toujours connu l'argile et les
potiers pour moi c'est ce que j'ai à
l'intérieur c'est tout ce qui fait
vibrer donc pour moi il ya une suite
logique dans ce que j'ai appris dans ce
que je peux transmettre maintenant c'est
comme une évidence
j'ai passé le premier c ap c'est du coup
pour moi il ya une boucle qui ce qui se
ferme et avec toute une ouverture sur
l'ensemble des stagiaires qui viennent
de toutes les régions possibles et
imaginables de tout tout tout les ages
puisqu'on on pas 18 ans à genève
bon séjour de cuisson chez le céramiste
alain godbert l'enfournement des pièces
dans le four a été effectué avec
précaution le feu est allumé depuis la
veille alain charge encore une fois le
petit feu foyer du bas avant de
l'obstruer
le grand feu foyer duo va démarrer
ah les poteries sont complètement
enveloppé par la table
donc quand tu es monté en 12 heures
c'est très bien pour les résultats la
conduite de la cuisson dans le caveau
bois est longue et délicate
il faut savoir gérer l'atmosphère du
four plus ou moins riche en oxygène est
monté progressivement en température
pour atteindre les mille 300 degrés
descendre charge et d'occident traverse
le four en modifiant la couleur des
aimants dans les aimants ya des premiers
qui ont tendance à la volatilisation
donc ça et tout le monde par un peu
aléatoire
je veux des rouges depuis vre depuis
vous parle dans l'atmosphère il faut
quand même qu'il en reste sur la pièce
pour que se retrouveront mais
quelquefois surtout bleus large il vous
sert à la fabrication des toits en
tuiles vernissées nous avons un bel
exemple ici au palais granvelle de
besançon citons aussi les hospices de
beaune en côte d'or
on parle souvent de tuiles vernissées
nous nous devrions plutôt dire tuiles
glaçure et soyons précis et il faut être
rigoureux car nous avons maintenant
rendez vous avec l'experte en la matière
auteur d'une thèse sur le sujet dans la
dernière fabrique de côte-d'or c'est
laurent
bonjour vous êtes en plein travail oui
on a fabriqué des tuiles plates
d'où vient l'argent la carrière est
situé à 500 mètres ici donc on fait
l'extraction une fois par an elle est
scripté ici sur la plate forme et donc
on la passe dans différentes machines
pour la rendre malléable à obtenir une
pâte douce
cette roue pointe essaiera sera percé
les cuves pour qu'elle soit relâchée
ici vous posez les tuiles terre fraîche
sur des tuiles anciennes courbe est donc
allé nouvelle tuile
m
une courbure donc chaque tuile chaque
support une tuile ancien qui est un
galbe différence se soit pas régulier
comme des tuiles des points industriels
qui sont vraiment en tout deux
identiques les unes par rapport aux
autres sans les murs permet de faire
mieux glisser l'autre fli tout à fait
d'avoir un meilleur recouvrement de la
toiture
après avoir été découpé perd ses marques
et les tuiles d'argile sont séchés à
l'air libre
puis un séchoir pendant une huitaine de
jours avant d'être plutôt furent a mis
40 degrés
ce n'est qu'après ce processus bien
spécifique que vient le temps
d'appliquer la glaçure donc là vous
passez la première couche en mélange
d'albums et d'émail blanc pour donner à
fond blanc sur la tuile donc pour
l'instant peut pas du tout distinguer la
couleur pour l'instant peut pas discuter
distinguer la couleur en après après
cuisson deuxième puissant 9 180 degrés
on va obtenir un marron foncé
pratiquement noirâtre donc là nous avons
quelques tuiles cuite
oui avec ou sans englobe le fond blanc
ben initial et le la glaçure miel qui
devient jaune sas elle même c'est la
même blessure
voilà où tu es sorti du four donc on va
réaliser à losanges voilà un exemple les
différentes couleurs
c'est le principe des écailles de
poisson 1 pour l'étanchéité sinon si les
tuiles étaient toutes alignées l'eau
s'infiltrait sur les côtés et en décalé
lowell tombe ici ensuite est donc ce
décalage a une influence directe sur la
constitution des motifs puisqu'on est
bien seul à réaliser de lignes
verticales sur une toiture
non c'est difficile où elles n'ont
toujours on a toujours des transversales
des billets peut pas faire des lignes
verticales sont compliquées oui donc
uniquement des diagonales des lignes
horizontales et c'est pour ça qu'on
trouve essentiellement dans les motifs
des triangles et losanges des trams le
venger
chez les laurent la tuile est une
affaire de famille aux granges so
grignon au bord du canal de bourgogne se
trouve le cully anciennement géré par le
père puis par le frère d'éric fermé
depuis le milieu des années 70 l'endroit
est aujourd'hui entretenu par
l'association des tuileries de l'eau
soit qui en a fait un musée on y
retrouve de nombreuses machines outils
ayant servi à la fabrication des tuiles
de personnes bravo 3 personnes pour
mettre la galette dans le moule
le deuxième presse une par une
et puis un troisième employé va les
ranger dans les rayons séchoir jeune
australienne y avait plusieurs presse
comme ça qu'ils touchent en rien une
presse pour les tuiles plates une presse
pour les tomettes et puis notre presse
pour les briques pleines
cette presse-là et donc à fonctionner
jusqu'en 1960 environ
ouais encore en 1968 de faisans car là
encore la main risque pressez pas simple
non plus la rénovation d'un clocher
comtois ces fameux dômes aux couleurs et
aux formes très différentes il y en a
près de 660
au total nous avons suivi la
restauration de celui de trémoins en
haute-saône datant du milieu du 19e
siècle pour évoquer le travail
contemporain celui ci découvre heures
cet échantillon la lys il présentait le
décor qui sera posée sur le toit a tout
à fait le principe ce sera celui-là mais
en fait ils ont un système m2 un système
de chevron avec les tuiles qui sont dans
cet ordre là mais seulement avec 5 tu es
là chaque fois donc par rapport aux
anciennes par exemple comme celles qui
traînent ici donc des couleurs qui sont
les plus proches
les tuiles anciennes ont vraiment là les
jeux les deux jaunes annonce très
semblables les formats turp a changé
c'est toujours la même largeur qui
environ 15 centimes et et puis 27 28 cm
de long donc ça c'est des tuiles qui ont
déjà vécu deux or celle ci
oui oui ça c'est des tuiles qui ont dit
très difficile de dater les tuiles je
dirais que ça c'est des éléments qui ont
150 ou 200 ans
c'est à dire que c'est peut-être des
éléments qui date de la construction
d'églises
si vous voulez je vous propose que qu'on
monte jusqu'à la charpente et sonner les
cloches et voilà un problème on pourra
voir ça de plus pour la restauration
d'un tel ouvrage
les tuiles sont sélectionnés avec l'aval
de l'architecte des bâtiments de france
c'est lui qui choisit leur couleur et le
motif qu'elles vont dessiner
il en faudra près de 7000 pour couvrir
ce clocher c'est un poids de 8 tonnes et
demie qui reposera entièrement sur la
charpente
on en est arrivé à aller au bout du
clocher donc lhi si par exemple on peut
hélas vous avez des systèmes de fixation
des tués dans les tuiles sont fixés par
année là comme ça accroché sur le lit
tôt les premiers on ne peut pas les
ligatures et donc les premiers à envoyer
moins que chloé et ensuite toutes les
tuiles sont ligaturer dire qu'il est
fils de cuivre qui pensent à travers on
passe ce film subito on le remonte par
dessus la tuile et ont fait une boucle
pour serrer le fil elle doit rebondir
un couvreur qui reste en bas qui
approvisionne il ses collègues avec le
chariot toutes les tuiles
il fait les chariots avec le nombre de
tuiles qui correspond au dessin et le
couvreur composent son dessin en
fonction du calepin qu'on lui a donné
voilà les salles aux dessins de dessin
se compose comme ça quand on a des
clochers qui sont très mauvais état à
sont là on pas qu'on utilise une
technique qui consiste à lever le
clocher descendre et elles réparer au
sol au sol elles sont là puisqu'on l'a
descendue on refait la couverture haut
sur l'eau aujourd'hui on a des grues qui
sont suffisamment puissante pour lever
un clocher complet un crochet complet
comme ça avec sa couverture
c'est un élément qui fait entre 13 et 16
17 tonnes donc mais aujourd'hui on a des
grue suffisamment puissante pour pouvoir
faire ses opérations d'un sac parce
qu'elle est simplement posé le rapport
entre la hauteur et la masse est tel que
y'a pas absolument aucune fixation dans
la maçonnerie
on a le pied douche ou dessus on à la
pointe avec le coq bien sûr le temps et
la boule la boule qui symbolise le monde
dans laquelle on parle qui a toujours
des secrets qui a toujours des choses
enfermé live que les coureurs qui font
les clochers
m dans la boule leur nom le nom de
l'équipe de la de l'équipe municipale
et puis aussi un journal de l'époque
pour dater leur date et les travaux
pour les chrétiens le coq est l'emblème
du christ bienfaiteurs il annonce
l'arrivée du jour après la nuit de la
lumière
après les ténèbres aujourd'hui la
plupart de ces girouettes sont fabriqués
de manière industrielle
mais à l'origine chacun de ces coques a
été conçu à la main par un artisan
nous voici achi c'est sur lui dans
l'atelier de bernard huguenin il fut un
temps où bernard travailler ses terres
et élevait ses animaux depuis quelques
années il s'est mis à fabriquer des
girouettes les coques notamment qui
ornent les toits des maisons alentour
c'est un homme passionné amoureux de son
terroir et fidèle aux traditions qui
l'habitent
pour concevoir ses créations bernard
travaille à l'aide d'outils modernes
selon des méthodes et des techniques
ancestrales
les matériaux utilisés sont choisis avec
soin car ces girouettes exposées en
plein ciel se doivent de résister à tous
les vents les coques sont fabriqués en
cuivre puisqu'ils ne s'oxyde pas y
roulent pas qu'aux qui est perché à 30
mètres de haut ne va pas être visité
tous les jours donc il utilisait
forcément ces matières de cuivre pour la
durabilité souvent un coq qui reste très
longtemps moi j'ai toujours vu le mien
seront logés puis je pense qu'il va
encore y rester encore quelques années
le coq ne possède pas qu'une valeur
symbolique dans le passé posé tout là
haut au sommet des clochers
cet animal pouvait s'avérer très utile
pour les habitants des villages
c'était le premier outil de météorologie
pour les paysans qui travaillaient la
terre
sachant que dès que la jirs une tournée
au nord ça voulait dire que c'était du
beau temps qui arrive et là on
s'affairait à des travaux de champs au
moment des points on aller faucher tout
ça et dès que le vent tournait pour
venir au vent de la pluie donc du sud
ouest là il fallait se dépêcher de finir
ses travaux sachant que la girouette
annoncé la pluie
les magiciens de la matière après la
terre la pierre sans les pierres de
bourgogne franche comté paris n'aurait
pas tous répondent ses monuments jeudi
paris mais beaucoup d'autres vivent du
monde c'est même cas comme besançon
d'ailleurs il reste d'une quinzaine de
carrière en bourgogne à l'origine de 80
pierre différentes
les techniques d'extraction heureusement
ont beaucoup évolué nous avons donné
rendez vous à une géologue et un
responsable de carrière en côte d'or à
comblanchien c'est l'un des plus
importants gisements
qu'est ce que c'est grand c'est exploité
depuis longtemps aussi la pierre oui
comme un chien est exploité à peu près
depuis le milieu du 19e siècle avec un
rythme d'exploitation de plus en plus
soutenue vous pensez qu'il ya plusieurs
dizaines de millions de mètres cubes qui
ont été extraits de ces carrières
tout n'est pas du calcaire de
comblanchien dans cette carrière et tout
n'est pas utilisé comme pierre marbrière
non pas du tout le comblanchien est
extrait dans les derniers quarante
mètres et au dessus on a un découvert
qui est en fête de la pierre également
mais qui a été dégradé par l'érosion
on trouve du bloc à partir d'une
quarantaine de mètres de profondeur au
tout le reste donc la partie du
découvert la partie supérieure est
utilisé pour le granulat donc en
concassées
au fond de cet immense chantier à ciel
ouvert à 40 mètres sous le niveau du sol
le calcaire de comblanchien est la
matière précieuse de cette carrière
alors ici l'explosif n'est pas utilisé
lapierre et si en bloc monumentaux d'où
son aspect lisse pour être exploitées
ensuite dans la construction
l'aménagement urbain ou encore la
sculpture de contrer une grosse
tronçonneuse qui travaillent directement
dans l'eau dans le calcaire en fait à
quelqu'un directement
on a beau se tient près de 50
qui va permettre de faire une tranchée
dans la pierre en descendant dans le
rocher comme
petite halte points derrière kim et
relance qu'on appelle les campings c'est
à dire les poussières
la machine va extraire
c'est amusant c'est vous on a
l'impression de se retrouver au moment
du dépôt du calcaire de comblanchien ans
était un lagon bleu turquoise et qu'une
bout ou si vous carbonatées se déposer
au fond de l'avion
là tu vois la machine qui permet de
tirer le câble diamantaire en faisant
tourner on tourne à peu près à 40 mètres
par seconde en convoi le film qui rentre
et qui ressort de la marque
c'est donc ce câble diamanté donc les
petites perles
on a ici avec des entretoises et des
ressorts sont recouvertes de petits
grains qui en fait du diamant
synthétique et ce diamant synthétique va
faire comme une grosse ribeiro ongles
eva fraiser dans la pierre donc on va
pouvoir couper une masse comme celle ci
en adoptant une demi-journée ya un petit
peu de temps mise en place et la machine
recul sur des rails en tirant pour le
câble c'est un petit peu comme un fil à
couper le beurre lui qualités techniques
et mécaniques proche du marbre de la
pierre de comblanchien pour que sa
renommée dépasse désormais les
frontières de l'europe aux états unis
les architectes du cubisme pour revêtir
les façades des immeubles en chine pour
la construction des villas de luxe à
taïwan dans le dallage des gratte ciel
si on parle du condom chien c'est
vraiment ses qualités physiques et
mécaniques qui permettent de l'employé
sous tous les climats et dans toutes les
utilisations qui ont fait que une pierre
qui est bonne pour tout à la fois la
construction massive comme le club aux
jo est aujourd'hui le revêtement
pédiculaires dans une cabine d'avion par
exemple c'est possible aussi ses caisses
- de pierre qui peut être qualifié de
pierre de luxe pour certaines
utilisations
le travail des matériaux un défi relevé
également par les architectes
le plus étonnant est symbolique sans
doute celui de la colline de ronchamp
haute saône
nous étions là leurs différentes étapes
de construction du monastère des soeurs
clarisses dessiné par renzo piano tout
près de la chapelle signé le corbusier
une commande passée en 2006 il
s'agissait cette fois de sculpter de
façonner le béton dans ce lieu fréquenté
chaque année par plus de 80 mille
personnes
c'est un tout petit projet pour l'équipe
de renzo piano comme pour les autres
projets de lagence les détails comptent
et la trilogie couleurs lumières
végétation est déclinée sur la matière
première du chantier le béton
je pense que là il avait encore un peu
et ce qui est intéressant pour nous
c'est la lumière qui ressort la dent au
soleil après on va voir les jardins
d'hiver il ya quand même cette lumière
qui va se voir et on va voir les ombres
des trams dans l'univers tout le monde
est partant pour être très attentionné à
la qualité et et finalement on sait plus
trop bien faire du béton coulé en place
ou alors ce sont des entreprises très
ferme à sophistiqué et dès qu'on veut du
travail soigné
le khat ont fabriqués on a on a perdu le
sens de l'artisanat la qualité sur le
chantier d'été d'exécution sur place
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut un
encadrement pointu ça veut dire qu'il
faut prendre du temps c'est à dire qu'il
faut suivre énormément les équipes
ça veut dire que les équipes doivent
être motivés
les clarisses elles ont vendu leur
monastère de besançon et vivent déjà sur
place et à l'étroit dans deux maisons
dessiné par le corbusier au pied la
chapelle elle et resteront 18 mois l'
avantage c'est de voir leur monastère se
construire sous leurs yeux
entre deux avions renzo piano vient
régulièrement à ronchamp chaque décision
et mûri l'architecte a fait sienne la
devise de galilée essayé et essayer
encore
c'est un espace petit et l'équilibré
important je comprends pas pourquoi ne
pas mettre comme il faut tant m je suis
plein de vie c'est pas mal mais vous
avez vu de l' équilibre de l'espace
serait génial puisque du coup quand vous
êtes là deux ans vous avez ce qui est
plutôt logique c'est venir 9 l'excès
cela ferait le fond comme ça le profond
peut-être les frites dedans quand ça
sera en entier je crois qu'il faut même
l'instant c'est trop tôt de miksa je
vais pas me battre avec les claviers
travailler pour déclarer c'est un peu
particulier
c'est surtout le budget qui est série et
on a fait deux essais pour l'esa les
salles de bain en fait à une entreprise
italienne de carrelage qui nous a fait
propos de nous faire don de ses
carrelages pour les dons oui donc non
plus pour les verticales et en plus
c'est très beau parce que c'est sermonné
semi artisanale aisée c'est de grès
cérame est pressé ça jamais été fabriqué
encore donc c'est un vrai pote tombe
voilà donc ont donc si tu veux tu vois
on a quand même ça va pas s'amuser à
faire une fan les a mis là pour que tu
vois et donc c'est une très belle
matière parce qu'elle n'est pas
régulière un oui mais s'est donné un
temps p de fret en paye de transport et
chaque projet a une histoire mais chaque
logis c'est un petit peu une nouvelle
aventure dans laquelle on tâche de créer
des émotions
hilale les émotions sont sont celles du
règlement du silence il rapport avec
avec la terre et maintenant avec la
chapelle qui est derrière et qu'on ne
range pas du tout puisque d'ici on n'a
pas la belle ville à cheval on voit pas
ici je pense qu'on y est je pense que
c'est bon on est encore six mois déjà le
seul selon là et on va encore me mettra
chaque phrase cela une surprise puisque
chaque fois on approche je vous
conseille une balade virtuelle sur notre
site internet pourquoi chercher plus
loin point fr vous y reverrai
l'intégralité de nos découvertes de la
chapelle de ronchamp des clochers de
monthois de la pierre de bourgogne de la
tradition peut-il refuser et des tuiles
vernissées d'hier à demain
pourquoi chercher plus loin
riant
tu
la semaine prochaine dans pourquoi je